but is not 1 very strange idea
from the Dutch bank
it is the task of the dutch bank
to advise on 1 obligation to become more sustainable
because that's what we're talking about
it is indeed not 1 tune about stimulating isolation
it's about the duty to get your house
to be made more sustainable
that costs tens of thousands of euros
that's what the bnb is talking about
what do you think of the rivm
what does the state secretary think
that the Dutch bank
this suggests
for me it is the task of the dutch bank
supervise our banks
supervise payment transactions
they come 1 kind of climate
climate ridle
which we could do very well without
and it is not creepy that the dutch bank
just we are going to use the savings
of the Dutch
I believe they say
percent of the homeowner has sufficient savings
that is therefore also possible to make it more sustainable
we all know that green grab bag here from D66
there is rolling out everywhere
to people's wallets
but in this case
just think it's 1 scary idea that now even the savings
is being attacked by people
the Dutch bank does not determine that